[Music]
if you had a bumper sticker and you
wanted a quick dirty definition of moral
grandstanding it's the use of moral talk
for self-promotion grandstander czar
moral showboaters they they use public
discourse as a vanity project they're
less concerned about saying what's true
they might be less concerned about
helping other people they're less
concerned about contributing to a
conversation that might be productive
more specifically someone might want to
be seen as having a spectacular
superhuman insight into what is just
some people might want to be seen as
caring the most about the poor or about
the troops some people might want to be
seen as the most affected by some
injustice
so grandstanding doesn't always look
like the same sort of animal
grandstanding sometimes looks like
piling on you often see cases of piling
on when a lot of people join in on a
shame fest for someone who's whose
misspoken or engage in a small minor Mis
fraction in order to signal to their
in-group or to their enemies that they
have a heightened sense of justice they
pile on in cases of public blaming and
shaming another form that grandstanding
takes is what we can call ramping up
ramping up involves trying to outdo each
other in moral discourse you can think
of it as a kind of moral arms race so I
might say something like the Senators
behavior was highly unacceptable
she should clearly be censured for it
now you not wanting to be undone might
say something like yes I agree that her
behavior was wrong but it's clearly way
out of bounds
she should no longer hold her office she
should be
impeached and then someone else again
not wanting to be outdone might say
someone who is long stood on the side of
injustice we should look into the
criminal law this cannot go unpunished
we must remember the world is watching
and you can think of more ramping up in
terms of what psychologists call social
comparison social comparison theory says
roughly we think of ourselves in
comparison to others so if I think of
myself as caring deeply about the poor
or about the troops that's going to be
important to me I'm gonna think of
myself as a more just person or more
caring person than my peers what happens
in conversation is is that once people
reveal their positions about how much
they care about or how affected they are
up by some problem you can now look like
you don't care as much as others about
some problem and so in order to to beat
someone else to the moral race or in the
moral race you have to outdo them and so
this often results in people taking more
extreme stands and they might otherwise
do on reflection because when the world
is watching you must show that you care
more moral philosophers tend to think
there's three main ways for something to
be morally good or bad one
it could have morally good or bad
consequences two it could be morally
good or bad insofar as it mistreats
other people or shows them respect or
disrespect and that's irrespective of
the bad or good consequences it might
have and third philosophers will often
say something like something is good or
bad if a virtuous person would do it or
not do it so we think about the virtues
like honesty courage we think that
grandstanding is bad according to all
three ways of thinking that something
could be morally good or bad
grandstanding has bad consequences we
argue that it contributes to political
polarization it increases levels of
cynicism about moral talk and its value
in public life and it causes a kind of
outrage exhaustion you know imagine if
you get outraged about everything in
order to show how good you are outraged
is no longer a reliable signal of
serious and justice in the world and
it's going to be harder for you to
muster outrage when it actually is
called for if we're outraged about
everything in order to show our moral
qualities so for those reasons
grandstanding is probably going to have
unbalanced negative consequences
grandstanding is also disrespectful so
one way to think about this is you know
I don't have you ever had live in a
neighborhood where they come around and
ask for collections for mosquito
treatments the mosquito cribs are gonna
happen no matter what and they asked for
you to contribute but you could get all
the benefits of the mosquito treatment
without chipping in it's called free
riding grande Stander's are a kind of
free rider so they get the benefits of
having public discourse and moral talk
go well when other people say don't
grandstand but Grand Stander's are free
riding because they're getting extra
benefits that they don't allow others to
have so think about a world in which
everyone was all the time just
grandstanding in public discourse that
would not be a world you want to live in
so grand standards as it were defect
from the norm they defect from the rules
that other people are following in order
to get extra benefits for themselves
that's it's a way of treating other
people with disrespect so way of not
doing your fair share it's a way of not
playing fair we also think the
grandstanding tends to reveal bad
character we think that most people who
engage in public discourse should do so
because they either want to help other
people or because they want to help
people do what's right and see what's
true grand standards however are in it
for themselves their egoistic
so imagine a group of acquaintances who
are on the one hand discussing world
historic injustice and on the other
fighting or arguing about who's most
offended by it I mean our view this is
just not how a virtuous person would
engage in public discourse so look on
balance we think grandstanding is
probably morally bad it probably has
more to recommend against it than in
favor of it
[Music]